let's get you into your top five
takeaways from sunday let's start with
sunday night sunday night football we
were there pittsburgh and this
pittsburgh team it's such an interesting
group right now defense looks like it's
championship built they have play makers
claypool deontay johnson on the outside
or some young exciting players uh big
ben back there is a question mark in and
of himself where's your temperature with
this pittsburgh team right now coming
out of sunday night
you know what just being there you
really get a got a chance to get a feel
for the team and playing against big
bands when he was a rookie in 2004 and
just seeing his career over the say the
last decade everything came so easy to
big ben
and you watch him play now and it's just
like you hold your breath and
it's just like you get nervous every
time he drops back and when he's pump
faking he just
he just doesn't see the field he doesn't
have the natural quick instincts like he
used to and they're just a different
offense and if yeah you look at this i
mean i've never seen this happen to big
ben like and he's barely moving to try
to even get to the ball i mean look at
this this doesn't happen to ben
roethlisberger
you know and this is something that it's
just it's just bad form man and you
can't rely on a defense every single
week to bail you out they're gonna have
to get production from ben and they're
gonna have to find a way to make this
offensive line a lot better because they
got a stud running back and
they're not gonna be able to live with
stuff like this with coming from big ben
it's just not gonna work
yeah they're gonna if they're gonna want
to make this a playoff run if they're
gonna want to turn this thing into a
playoff run they're gonna have to get
the duct tape out a little bit you know
because with big ben you're just going
to be playing around some stuff and
within some of his limitations and one
of those big ones is that he likes to be
in the shotgun big ben doesn't like to
be under center sometimes even reaching
handoffs is a challenge for him just
trying to get that thing out there for
like a stretch handoff it is a full
exercise for him to get there that's why
if you watch the steelers play they run
more draws from shotgun to the running
back than any team i've really ever seen
it's because big ben prefers to be back
there so what i would do a lot of is
take naji harris go five wide put him in
the slot and match him up against
linebackers against safeties and make
240 pounds with the speed and quickness
and athleticism and hands that he has
let that be an extension of your of your
running game and your passing game too i
thought we saw a little bit of that in
this sunday night game and my
expectation is for that to continue
because he is awesome playing receiver
same thing that we talked about sunday
night and we were having that same
conversation and i said how do you
soften this defense well you spread them
out and you get your running back
involved too he's an excellent wide
receiver out of the backfield he's
leading your team in receptions just
five five spread them out empty
formation now you let big ben but the
only thing that really concerns me about
big ben especially with the weather
changing we saw a we went from 80 90
degrees to all of a sudden we're in 50
degree weather and then in the next
month or so we're going to be in 30 and
40 degree weather do you have any
concern about big ben being as old as he
is being able to function in the cold
weather because it's not getting any
warmer
yeah i got concerns about him
functioning in any weather right now if
i'm being honest with you i just he
he has to step into a throw for him to
really get what he wants to on a pass he
has to have space the ability to step
into it and really put his whole body
weight behind one and then still it
doesn't look like what a big bend throw
used to but my big concern is that he
used to be able to have guys draped off
him and sort of one guy on his shoulder
any stiff arms and then he can still put
some sauce on it to go get a first down
or that's not a reality for him anymore
like when somebody's on him or he has to
do a big pump fake it can fall out of
his hands there's just certain 40 year
old things that seem to be a pattern
with his game that week after week we
see so that's why i'm saying they're
going to have to come up with band-aids
and duct tape to just call plays around
big ben in this final year before in my
opinion they go get a mobile running
quarterback uh like the rest of the
league has done i think their adaptation
is getting ready to happen this off
season just a matter of duct taping
until then
yeah if i were mike tomlin i would start
rotating my back up quarterback in and
probably start giving him a a couple
series each game maybe a series or two
in the first half maybe a series or two
in the second half just to give ben a
little competition but also give the
backup quarterback a little bit more
experience with the first group just so
in case something happens but yeah i
mean anytime you start sharing some reps
with somebody it should wake you up and
i think that would be a great wake-up
call for big ben
yeah and we both really like this pat
fryer move as well it's the last guy i
want to give a little love to before we
move on because he's this this guy at a
penn state rod i know you really liked
him he reminds me of like heath miller
jason whitton like just sort of that
sure-handed
always open always just sort of
comfortable option for big ben uh what'd
you see from friarmuth in particular
they even give him the moo the whole the
whole heinz field gives the full move
just like they used to do with uh with
heath there when he would make a play
well they're they're really excited
about this young um tight end and he's
very athletic he's got good hands and he
can just make a difference and you talk
about eric ebron a guy that's been so up
and down and consistent in his career
but when you draft a guy like him you
could like this kid for our move you can
mold him to whatever you want him to
mold him in yeah he's going to have to
continue to work on his blocking a
little bit but as a receiver he's going
to be outstanding and like i told you
when we were there sunday night this kid
should get five or six targets every
game
yeah and he's working his way up to that
i that's about what he had sunday night
let's get to your second take away the
raiders a very tough week that they had
really away from the football field with
their coach moving on how were they able
to keep a focused mind and go get a win
man i was just so proud of the raiders i
mean think about your coach getting
fired and you have to go through the
whole media thing and the shock of a new
coach and all these different things and
then you have to play a divisional team
and a team that really knows you well
and how do you stay focused it's
leadership within that group and that um
i would say those veterans in that
locker room derek carr
probably got those guys together and
said look guys we can't control what's
going on as far as the coaches but we we
still have a job to do we're getting
paid handsomely to go out here and
handle business that's exactly what they
did i was so proud of the raiders
because i was like okay if this is this
the same old raiders because the same
old raiders would have came out felt
sorry for themselves and would end up
losing that game and they didn't they
hung in and they fought
yeah i got i got to give some serious
love to derek carr i just think for carr
this is a real leadership moment for him
this is one where he's got to step up
and go guys this season's not over i
mean this isn't a situation where our
goals are behind every goal that we
still have as the las vegas raiders is
still ahead of us right i mean they can
still do ever they can still chase a
super bowl this year so so for him to
refocus this group uh really is
impressive and i thought carr had some
awesome touch throws in this game he's a
quarterback this is one right here he
just puts air under the football and
gives his receivers a chance the rugs
touchdown uh he did that on there was
another third and six where he hit
edwards and just putting air under look
at he just how he just gives the
receiver a chance that time it's wall or
coming let me ask you a question that's
an impressive thing we see from carr go
ahead rob
i was going to ask you do you feel like
because you know how john grewn is he's
such a
hands-on coach do you feel like this
might even freed carr up a little bit
where he doesn't have that guy on top of
him criticizing him being so critical of
every little single thing because it
looks like when he was out there he was
just slinging the ball it looked easy
whereas before with john gruden he's
like
throws and then he looks to the sideline
to see if it's okay this might even free
him up a little bit who knows jack
i i i agree with you because he's
surrounded by talent now rod in a way
that he hasn't been for a long time
there with the raiders i mean he hasn't
had this kind of talent his whole career
really so you think about the defense
that they have the wide receivers that
they have waller josh jacobs coming out
of the backfield so now finally he's
loaded with talent and i just think
gruden was the hardest play caller head
coach for any quarterback to play with
because he's so demanding and critical
of every little mistake and he's so sort
of brash and huge about the way he'll
sort of embarrass you if you do make a
big mistake so absolutely do i think
this could be freeing for the mind of a
guy like carr and it might it might very
well everything i've heard about this
special teams coach coming in it might
be a good thing for him given what kind
of personality this guy has and
breathing that through to the whole
roster
amen man just you know special teams
coach he doesn't really he's kind of
just loyal to everybody he's not an
offensive guy he's not a defensive guy
and you know you see him working with
the special teams guys and normally
those are back up guys and you have a
lot of respect from the younger players
and the backup guys but also you see the
veteran players always being a part of
the special team so when he walks in
right away believe it or not the special
teams coach always have credibility
because he deals with everybody he deals
with offensive line the defensive line
on on field goal block and all those
different things so good for him man
that was a that was a huge win against a
divisional um opponent
huge huge win in in crosby our guy max
crosby man another mega he's a monster
12 pressures
three sacks seven hurries i was just
going through the whole league 43 total
pressures he has on the year leads the
entire league 25 quarterback hits that's
first in the nfl 11 quarterback
pressures or excuse me 25 hurries 11
quarterback hits so in every pass
rushing statistic he is first in the nfl
that's my defensive player of the year
so far rodney i don't think it's
particularly close either crosby has
been a monster this season oh that's not
how could you say something like that
how could you look at me in the streets
of a former defensive back in the
national football league and forget
about that boy diggs from the dallas
cowboys how can you forget about him you
do you understand how hard and difficult
it is to play cornerback in the national
football league and have seven picks and
and pick sixes come on jack what's up
with you man ask your dad go ask your
dad how difficult it is to play
quarterback
oh i i believe it's it's darn difficult
and he's he's having a huge year and
he's coming up with all kinds of
interceptions and pick sixes it feels
like every week but i mean this is
somebody who's going up against
watt jj watt aaron donald the best pass
rushers tj watt and week after week he
is pulling away from him in every pass
rush statistic and he's some no name
nobody's talking about crosby he's not
some superstar name we throw around but
week after week he is producing like
nobody else on the defensive interior
and so so far for me he's the guy he is
the guy
hey hey i'm not mad at you but i'm just
telling you what diggs is doing is
unheard of it's unreal what he's doing
interception basically every single game
and return them for pig six and just
think about how that the strategy
affects the offense because now you're
pretty much limited to one side of the
field but yeah i mean you can't go wrong
i love crosby the energy and the
leadership that he's bringing and you
can tell i mean it's infectious you see
casey herrera you see all the rest of
these guys flying around making plays i
love it
speaking of an infectious personality
naji harris rod we were on the field
right after that pittsburgh win and naji
came out for that post game enter that's
one of one of my favorite interviews
i've ever been a part of ever i even
want to go back to a little clip artist
remember that jamal adams hit we're like
we got to ask him about this jamal he
brought it up before we even brought it
up to him let's run that clip this is
noddy harris right after the win
how did you use your full skill set to
get this win tonight on the field man
i'll tell you what
that's a good ass defense
hey when jamal adams came and rung my
belt oh i was going to ask you about
that hey i just have to get up hey good
hit man
that's a good hit yeah i know did you
see him coming at all or no i saw him
coming but he got so low i tried to meet
him there man
rung my bell talk about but that's the
stuff i like right there okay you know i
mean that's real fool that's the
football i like right there
hey he said go ahead
listen he said that's the stuff i like
he rang my bell this dude loves it he
man let me tell you something it was so
much fun just you know we get a chance
to talk to these young kids man and to
see the personality and just see how
humble and just how fun and full of the
spirit he was a guy that really truly
loves football that's what i love about
this game it's not just the tackles and
the big hits but being able to spend
time with young guys like that and and
just see how much you know how how good
of young people they are they're just
good young people
he is going to be a phenom up there in
pittsburgh man how long after that game
did those fans hang out they were
chanting his name it's like one a it's
an overtime game it's like 1am it's cold
it's you know mid-october late october
pittsburgh cold and they are chanting
his name till about 1 o'clock in the
morning i just think his personality
gives that backfield a little bit of
pittsburgh steelers to it again you know
what i mean like the offensive line's
got two rookies up there i think they
have a lot more confidence in the
running back coming out of the backfield
than they do the offensive line but it's
bringing confidence into this whole
group uh and jamal adams he was he was
he's somebody you're real close with rod
you talked to him before the game he had
that huge shot right there that we were
just talking about on harris how should
they maybe adjust his role what was some
of the some of the messaging coming out
of that conversation you shared with him
a week ago
well we talked about it we you and i
talked about in the pregame show and the
fact that they were using him in a deep
part of the field and to me if i got a
jamal adams i don't use him in a deep
part of the field because you're really
taking him away from what he does best
his strengths his strengths is being
around the line of scrimmage the god kid
had nine and a half sacks last year as a
defensive back that's unheard of the
most i've ever had in one season was six
he had nine and a half put him close to
the line of scrimmage where he's natural
so what i would do if i were the
defensive coordinator i would actually
move jamal adams to linebacker next to
bobby wagner i would bring ryan neal in
he's a 6-3 safety he's long he can cover
you know he can come down he can be that
extra box guy he can cover tight ends
and now you got jamal in the box where
he's comfortable now you can create some
one-on-one match-ups he can come off the
end and go against running backs and
tight ends but i would definitely move
jamal adams i wouldn't have him in a
deep part of the field because you
negate or you take away what he does
best and jamal adams is a stub when he's
around that box
this is a really interesting point i i
actually i love that you are making this
point rod because i drew tranquil did
this with the chargers and it wound up
really giving his career second life he
was a college safety and a thick one he
played big he liked to play on his toes
just like jamal adams does and they
moved him up to linebacker and he went
from being an okay maybe below average
cover safety to being an elite coverage
linebacker and i think the same thing
would happen to jamal adams because when
he got up there he's 213 215 pounds but
he plays like he's about 230 235 right
like you never see him getting moved
around or bullied here's a good example
right here is he goes earhole right
there of naji harris and the respect
that naji showed him i think he is going
to look like himself again if you start
bringing him down in that box he just
looks so much more comfortable right
there
he does and and you know what we used to
do with the patriots we played with
three safeties and i was actually the
nickelback but in our system the
nickelback had to cover the slot so i
had to go one-on-one against all these
little these guys like heinz ward and
all these other dudes i had reggie wayne
i had to deal with in the slot where if
you move him to linebacker the thing
that he'll probably have to worry about
may be a tight end every now and then
but for the most part a lot of backs
coming out the backfield and that's what
you give him so now he can just play
free he can play reckless and he doesn't
have to worry about the deep part of the
field
i like that a lot let's get to sort of
the top of the afc right now right so
the chargers get beat up buffalo loses
to tennessee are the chiefs or the
kansas city chiefs who just beat
washington are they becoming a sleeping
giant again as we're sort of looking at
all these other teams that are emerging
are we forgetting about the top dogs
what i tell you what i tell you earlier
i told you don't forget about this those
chiefs man one thing about the chiefs
when you have a successful team and
you've been in super bowls and stuff
like that you understand you're going to
have some ups and downs some
inconsistencies but this is a veteran
team and they have the most competitive
guy in the national football league and
patrick mahomes so you better believe
he's going to get that team going the
defense will bounce back get a couple
more guys healthy but don't forget about
the chiefs they have everything you need
from an offensive standpoint they still
have that veteran coaching staff and you
know andy reid he is a very competitive
coach he's going to be right there in
the mix and plus eric the enemy's trying
to find a job too he's trying to find a
head coaching job so these guys are all
into it just don't forget about the
chiefs and in two or three weeks you're
going to be looking at me like roger you
told me not to forget about the chiefs
just watch out for the chiefs
yeah
this season is such a marathon these
days with the extra game doesn't it just
feel like the season's this feels like
it's just one game they added it feels
like they added 10 games it's just like
this whole thing just feels like a
marathon so september football is just
like okay these teams are still figuring
out who the heck they are october
football is starting to get real
november it's good we're going to really
figure out who the legit teams are and i
think you're already starting to see
that process starting to play out
a little bit you still some weird
moments from the homes like i'm thinking
about the one where he dropped the snap
and then just sort of lobbed it up to
like five washington players so there's
still a few of those the second
interception was tyrique right in the
hands which continues to happen he put
his hands right on it boom pops over his
head for an easy interception so i'm not
as worried about that one as i am the
one where he just lobbed it up to the
middle of the defense uh and the one guy
i still want to see more of is meet cole
hardman there's no sami watkins so me
cole hardman has to step up as that
number three play maker and he had
another fumble this week which was a big
turnover and let washington hang around
in that game longer than they should
yeah when you have fumbles and things
like that coaches start to lose trust
and faith in you and if they lose trust
and faith that means they're not going
to give you the ball so let's go to the
next one yeah
let's get to the next one the next one
that we have is jared goff okay so just
give me your that's your boy give me
your message on jared goff i'm not
putting any words in your mouth on this
one
well
dan campbell's he's talking about jared
goff needs to step up he needs to play
better like and i'm looking at dan like
jared goff is who he is like
he's average he's an average quarterback
and that's the reason why
los angeles was in such a rush to get
rid of him i mean after they paid him
the money and when when they actually
paid him the money everybody's looking
like they gave jared goff that type of
money like what's wrong with the rams
like their general manager should be
fired so when when he comes to detroit
you think he's going to be a better
quarterback i mean he had a perfect
ideal situation out there he had one of
the top defenses he had one of the top
young young minds in all of football
he's got weapons all over the place and
look at him he's owen six
oh in six four interceptions seven
touchdowns
jared goff is who he is he's an average
quarterback that got paid and he's
laughing all the way to the bank
yeah they are who we thought they were
that's kind of this reminds me of a
little bit right i mean it's like you
you ship him off there you ship a guy
off he was struggling in the perfect
situation to a team that's in a complete
and utter rebuild i mean this probably
isn't even a three-year rebuild this is
probably more the five-year variety i
mean this is going to take time they
don't have really any weapons that scare
you other than maybe tj hawkinson
defensively they're bad mixon was
running all over them jamar chase was
making the secondary look even worse so
there is all kinds of issues when you
look at detroit now they've been tough
they've been competitive they've been in
games up to this cincinnati game so at
least give them love for that but to
expect jared goff to go to detroit with
this team and win is unrealistic it's
just unrealistic and think about it like
if you're a free agent jack
you don't you're not going to detroit
like even if they try to overpay you a
couple million you're looking like i
don't want to go to detroit because at
times you feel like when you lose and
i've been in a losing situation when i
started off in san diego like when you
lose it takes the life out of you and
you feel like well it's not even really
football it's no longer it's not fun to
go to work anything like that so
i
jarrod golf is who he is he's just an
average quarterback and you know if they
thought they were going to get jared
goff and turn him into some pro bowl
quarterback or the best quarterback in
the nfc north they were crazy and that's
that's what i mean about these teams
they get so desperate they're willing to
sell their souls for a quarterback and
you get this guy and you know he's
garbage you know he is what he is
i think the rams just absolutely had to
get the mistake of that contract off
their books right so they had to get
golf out of there to go get what they
believed to be their super bowl
quarterback in stafford and the only
team desperate enough to take that
contract of jared goff was detroit as
they are basically already a dumpster
fire of a roster at this point uh and
this complete rebuild that we're
referring to goes into progress is he
gonna be there by the end of it i doubt
it is he there right now yes is he gonna
have to struggle through this process
yes do i feel bad for them that's also a
yes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports